sam haycock was saving up to buy a moped
he wanted to be more independent when he
started college
when school was out in may sam went
swimming with friends at a local
reservoir
no fear didn't see the danger
and despite not being able to swim he he
he jumped in the cold water hit sam and
he went into shock
disappearing underneath the surface
horrible horrible horrible day
waiting for news
and when i found it hard to believe
when that when that news came through
i still don't know still can't believe
it
simon doesn't know if he'll ever come to
terms with his son's death
but he's finding strength in fundraising
he wants more flotation devices near
open water
to give others a chance he says sam
never had
there was a ring within reach but
it with that you know the the trees were
that overgrown it was hidden
and it weren't it weren't in view of the
lads
that were with him swimming in
reservoirs like this can be fatal
even for strong swimmers and when people
need help
it's not always on hand what's in this
box can save
lives you can throw the line out to
someone who's drowning and try to pull
them in
but people are vandalizing and even
stealing equipment
and potentially ruining someone's chance
of survival
it's devastating for the emergency
workers who are just trying to keep
people alive
but to them it's not surprising they
regularly experience hostility
even violence i think stone throwing has
been
the sort of extreme of what we've faced
over the last few weeks but it it is
that sort of
not wanting to listen um not engaging
and we are there purely just to try and
make them safe
and the best way to stay safe don't go
for a swim if there are warnings
the number of people drowning spiked
during the recent heat wave
but trying to cool off in open water is
extremely dangerous
sam's family hope his death and their
fight will make people think
twice and save lives becky cottrell
sky news rotherham